les deux films sortent en même temps y'a
pas un numéro un et un numéro dont celui
qu'on veut sur le voir au smoking
d'abord d'abord n'ont pas écouté
woking nouveau king - instinctivement
j'ai néanmoins ce meeting dans l'ordre
quoi il n'ya pas bien du saut monté le
boucher 1 et pourquoi tu veux absolument
mettre un ordre mais pas du tout au
contraire vos plus simple est une vraie
plaie smoking no smoking
alors je vais voir smoking d'abord notre
politique ensuite ça paraît logique ou
même nom tu veux absolument discuter
alors non je n'ai pas discuté mais s'il
choisit quoi effectivement ça n'a aucune
importance et qu'il faut voir les deux
voilà les deux c'est ça qui est amusant
faut voir les deux rues no smoking
d'abord ça va mais surtout quand ils
voient qu'ils noueraient les mains d'un
truc allez on dit ça n'a pas
d'importance face on va pas les voir
chacun le sien
non j'ai envie d'aller au cinéma oui
mais moi aussi un holà oui toi tu
choisis tu dis ce que tu préfères et no
smoking à les voitures ces dix apprentis
en cuisine il ya plusieurs mois encore
fragile